[Applause]
all of the nominees for best adapted
screenplay
are phenomenal chloe zhao
born in china and raised in the uk came
to realize that her experience as an
outsider to the american dream
gave her a unique window into examining
it
that niche perspective drew her to nomad
land
rameen barrani nominated
nominated for the white tiger paid his
way to making his own
films working as a truck driver a
bartender and a telemarketer oh
telemarketing i may have hung up on you
a few times
uh kemp powers his own play
one night in miami he adapted it now
there are some fun facts
in this teleprompter but i'm gonna go
off script here
this was his first screenplay
before kemp was a playwright he was a
journalist
and one of his favorite films is animal
house
which is where he heard sam cook for the
first time
how about that florian zeller adapting
his play the father
saw the movie rain man and was inspired
to create a character
that allows us to understand alzheimer's
through the eyes of those
living it his collaborator christopher
hampton
was raised in cairo egypt and his movie
love
stems from his father taking him to the
movies three
times a week i bet tickets weren't
thirteen dollars a piece back then
okay here we go
sasha baron cohen dan mazur dan sweimer
erica rivenoya
jenna friedman anthony hines lee kern
peter bainum and nina pedrod for burat
subsequent movie film delivery of
prodigious bribe
to american regime to make benefit once
glorious nation
of kazakhstan
okay here we go
and the oscar goes to
christopher hampton and florian zeller
the father
[Music]
thank you thank you so much it's such a
great joy and such a great honor and i
share this joyce and and this award with
christopher hampton
we have uh worked together for years and
i want to thank him for being
such a great writer and such a wonderful
friend and i have to to thank everyone
involved in the father and everyone who
helped me to to make that film
uh that script becoming a film uh
my producers of course a simon friend
who first produced the play in london
the great david perfett philip garcon
jean-louis levy christophe spadon uh
the the the sony classics family uh
michael tom melody uh all my team at ca
hey brian sorry
so many names that i have to mention
federica chris andrew
laurent olivier and suzanne thank you
for being so supportive
and and the crew of the father of course
and the wonderful cast
olivia williams oliver coleman rufus
seal
margaritis emojin puts and of course
anthony hopkins
i wrote the script for him to me he's
he's the greatest the greatest living
actor and just the idea to work with him
was
was like a dream and i knew that it was
not an easy dream to fulfill because
i'm french as you can hear it was my
first feature film and
you know he's anthony hopkins but i
thought until someone comes and proves
that it was not possible it means that
potentially it is
and sometimes we are the one who closed
the door of what is possible and what is
not possible and for the father
i really wanted not to close that door
and to follow my
my inspiration my desire and my dream so
thank you anthony
for having said yes to that script and
thank you for having
given everything to that film your
energy
your grace and your talent uh sharing
that journey with you was
the most amazing experience of my life
and at last i wanted to thank my my wife
marina for supporting me
with love and patience uh thank you
to the academy
you